how do you feel about the Spectre of a
second Trump
Administration I will
move I can't live in this country if
that's if he became president but where
would you go where would you go if
probably to England mhm I like England
England is very nice but she's serious
she's not telling a joke here I would
move I would move if Trump became
president I couldn't live in this
country if Trump became president
except you did that's true I did I I did
and it was fine right you're totally
fine you're okay you're alive you're you
th you probably made even more money
than you previously had and everything
was fine well yeah but I couldn't do it
again this is why I think the the
reelect especially with this
intermediate period uh where Biden has
been president where everything's gone
to pot I think it puts Trump in a
stronger position because it it
defangs the the attacks